Завжди все починається з того,
що ти щось побачив і тобі сподобалось.
Почалося все з мрії.
Паразит такий у розумі оселився
— і все, вже нікуди від нього не подітися.
Як і будь-де: якщо тобі щось подобається,
ти зможеш чогось досягти у цій галузі.
Якщо ні, то краще кинути і не робити.
Дванадцять років тому я побачив кулю вперше.
І мені це сподобалось.
Спочатку я напросився в команду, допомагав.
Просто щоб бути причетним до цього всього.
Кілька років бігав за кулями і кошиками,
допомагав складати та розкладати.
І в мене визрівало рішення,
що треба розвиватися далі, вчитися на пілота.
У 2013 році я отримав ліцензію.
Як з'явилася нагода —  я одразу нею скористався.
З чим можна порівняти?
Це як яхтинг, найімовірніше.
Тільки яхти в одній площині можуть
рухатися за допомогою вітру,
а у нас безмежна кількість цих площин фактично.
Ми так само ловимо вітер, як яхти,
але ми можемо робити це на різній висоті.
Кам'янець унікальний тим,
що рельєф дає можливість маневрувати.
Кам'янець — це унікальне місто, воно дуже різне.
Воно завжди було дуже різним.
Не тільки через національне різномаїття.
Бо сотні років місто було то російське,
то польське, то трішечки турецьке.
І це все якось вплинуло на тих людей, які тут живуть.
На енергетику загальну — 100 % вплинуло.
Тому що так просто воно не проходить.
Це наше місто. І воно гарне.
Фестивалі проводяться вже традиційно.
І вони вже стали невід'ємною частиною
Кам'янця-Подільского і цієї всієї туристичної субкультури.
Проводяться два рази в рік: у травні і в жовтні.
Ми на початку травня відкриваємо туристичний сезон,
а в жовтні ми його закриваємо.
На ці фестивалі з'їзжаються всі охочі.
Це десь близько 20 куль.
Виглядає це класно!
Ця штука називається тепловий аеростат,
а це його нижня частина — кошик, гандола.
Хто як хоче, так його і називає.
Тут пілот і пасажири.
Без пілота не літаємо.
Просто без пілота не літаємо.
Щоб цією штукою керувати, треба вчитися.
Як на велосипеді треба вчитися їздити, а тут до кілометра
підніматися в небо, тож є багато нюансів.
Дуже все просто: 2 балони по 60 літрів,
шлангами під'єднані до спеціального пристрою,
що називається пальник.
Підігріваємо повітря всередині оболонки,
он оболонка у складеному вигляді.
Повітря теплішає — піднімаємося вгору.
Стає повітря прохолоднішим — ми спускаємося.
Все дуже просто.
І через те, що на різних висотах напрям
повітряних потоків трошечки відрізняється,
ми можемо вправо або вліво керувати кулею.
Ось так це все відбувається.
Теплові аеростати вважаються найбезпечнішими
засобами пересування повітрям
через те, що вимоги до метеорогічних умов дуже високі.
Сильний вітер — летіти не можна.
Дощ — летіти не можна.
Тому все завжди нормально.
Прилади прості: це радіостанція для зв'язку.
З цієї сторони (якщо ви зайдете з камерою) —
варіометр-альтиметр, він показує висоту кулі,
висоту над землею,
а тут — вертикальну швидкість кулі.
Тобто з якою швидкістю в метрах за секунду
ми піднімаємося вгору або спускаємося вниз.
Є кілька основних виробників цих куль.
Навіть колись в Україні шили повітряні кулі
на Феодосійському заводі.
Була Феодосійська парашутна фабрика.
Вони трошки переобладналися
та навчилися шити повітряні кулі.
Але після усім відомих подій [2014 р.] все змінилося.
У Чехії є, в Німеччині, в Іспанії.
В Європі є 5-6 основних фабрик, які займаються
пошиттям куль і роблять це вже десятки років.
Куля літає десь 500–600 годин.
А потім це вже ганчірочка.
Нова куля коштує близько €35 000
Це тільки куля,
а ще багато чого для неї треба.
Сезон повітроплавальний дуже сильно
прив'язаний до туристичного.
Коли приїжджають люди,
вони не бояться літати влітку.
Хоча насправді різниці взагалі немає ніякої:
влітку літати чи зимою.
Небо є небо. Воно завжди однакове.
Тільки зимою трошки холодніше.
Але взимку і на землі холодно.
І ми вдягаємося і ходимо, а не сидимо в хатах.
Так сталося, що пів року літаємо,
пів року сидимо і думаємо: де ж оте літо?
Перші роки, коли були ці кулі, то було:
«А, яка радість, кулі прилетіли».
А цього року були вже випадки,
що чи не з вилами вибігали,
коли приземлився на галявинці, а вона чиясь.
І прибігає навіть не власник, а якийсь його сусід:
«Що ви тут порозліталися?!»
Якось дивно дуже.
Питаєш: «Що, у вас щодня куля біля хати сідає?
У чому проблема? Ми ж вам нічого не пошкодили».
Але це дуже рідко.
Цього року вперше таке було,
скільки років ми вже цим займаємося.
Ми, звичайно, не проводимо ніяких психологічних тестів
перед тим, як садити людей у кошик.
Але якихось істеричних моментів
не було ще жодного разу.
Люди перестають боятися висоти,
от що найцікавіше.
Буквально перші дві-три хвилини, поки людина
вибудовує для себе розуміння  того, що відбувається,
а потім — все!
Починаються усі ці селфі,
коли наполовину з кошика вилізають.
Вже тоді я за них починаю боятися.
Майже 20 років тому,
коли був пік заробітчанства в Португалії.
Море, сонце, будова...
Потім багато шкодував,
що не повернувся туди з дружиною.
Коли щось не виходить,
думаєш: «У Португалії було б класно!»
А потім тут щось виходить і ти вже думаєш:
«Нормально, а в Португалії зараз би відра носив.
А тут он на кулі можна літати.
Добре, що додому повернувся».
І так завжди.